start tiger woods still recuperating  from a february car crash that severely  injured his legs and now  we know why the crash happened this  morning the l.a county sheriff revealed  woods was driving at least 84 miles an  hour when he crashed  twice the speed limit estimated speeds  at the first area of impact were 84 to  87 miles per hour  and the final estimated speed when the  vehicle struck the tree was 75 miles per  hour  investigators say woods didn't break  before the crash and it's possible he  hit the accelerator by mistake  the l.a county sheriff's department says  though woods showed no signs of  impairment  and no blood tests were taken woods says  he has no memory of the crash